foreign
about his relationship with his father I
said what do you think made you great he
said my parents told me they were going
to love me whether I scored every point
or no points
and he said one summer in basketball
like when he was 12 or 13 he was in a
summer league practicing playing in a
tournament for months he said he did not
score one point
and his dad and his mom were just like
we love we still love you we love you no
matter what we just want you to have fun
and he said it gave him permission to go
out and be great yeah and I kind of love
anchors you into Bedrock so you can
repel off right and you can do crazy
wild stuff and this goes back to uh
after I opened up about the sexual abuse
in this Workshop
I remember thinking to myself okay these
people in this group accepted me because
we were all kind of opening up about
different stuff
so they you know they're strangers okay
you know who cares what happens they're
safe but I was like I don't think I
could tell my family or my friends I
don't think they're gonna accept me I
talked to a therapist friend of mine and
I was like hey this thing just happened
I just talked about this and I'm
actually really scared because I don't
know if anyone else will accept me
how can I even bring this to family and
friends
and she gave me a great piece of advice
she said
a time to call them each individually
and ask them a question first and see
their reaction and then see how you feel
about it but ask them is there anything
I could ever say or do that would make
you not love me
and based on the response if you feel
comfortable then you can share
if they receive that and if they say
yeah absolutely not and I did that with
each one of my family members I said is
there anything you could ever say I
could ever say or do to make you not
love me and they're all like absolutely
not doesn't matter what you've done I'm
still gonna love you and it gave me
permission to reveal myself it gave me
permission to open up and be honest
about my shames and insecurities
and then I thought to myself okay well
these are my family they have to accept
me but my friends I don't know if they
will but it was a practice of going down
and because I still felt powerless if
other people knew this about me they
wouldn't accept or love me and I think
that's where it all comes back to but I
I what you did was really important and
I hope the listeners hear this
we have a again we live in such
polarized world but we either have
people who sit on on Secrets forever
yeah or we've got pathological
overshares yes right you're like hey
streaming vulnerability
yeah and then one time and you're like
dude and so it's context setting it's
time and place magic which is
you knocked said can I come in yes and
they said come on in if they're not
ready for it if they're making a joke or
like ah what are you gonna say you're
crazy and then maybe don't tell them
yeah exactly maybe and maybe they're not
they're not ready for it maybe they're
not ready for it yeah don't spew it on
everyone there you go yeah and I'm not
saying you need to share with everyone
in your life these things but I think
it's important yeah you got to share it
with someone right yes and if not and it
means you're unwilling to let people see
inside of you okay why is this harsh to
say it this way
um
if you're unwilling to let somebody to
have that conversation
they're in my head and man tell me I'm
wrong you can hit me even there's a
comes a moment when
you're choosing to stay here then
to stay stuck or stay in that past yes
and it and it pains me to to look at
somebody's experienced abuse experience
trauma experience marginalization and
say
from this point forward
you're choosing to stay here for a
season and that's okay you're free to do
that it's just more powerlessness it's
just you're powerless oh that thing has
power over you still yeah if you're
unwilling to reveal something or share
something or talk about something
because you're so afraid then you're
letting fear run your life yeah as
opposed to healing and peace and
acceptance of who you are or what you've
been through and here's the thing I am a
big believer I'm assuming you'll agree
with this that the the secret to a happy
life is relationships and the secret to
happy relationships is vulnerability
dude I wish I wish there could be any
other way any other way yeah I wish you
could just fake it and just make
everything a joke and like you know dude
rub off the past and not talk about it
just have a long text thread of funny
memes yeah that was it which has been
your life it sounds good it's everyone's
life
it's not there's not and when I had
these conversations with my family
members
and I opened up what do you think
happened they all started to be like
they all shared something about
themselves that I didn't know and it
created a bond a connection of like wow
I respect I trust you I appreciate you
more like this connection more I think
you can even flip that we also have a
pathological inability to say the good
stuff that's going on and we downgraded
right oh dude but like let's say you
cross a billion downloads or whatever
the threshold is yeah
do you have four five people you could
spook the phone and call and they would
go dude that's all right you know it's
all the good stuff too also when it says
you haven't interviewed a lot of people
on your show right yeah I just take
calls I've interviewed a lot of
some of the most famous people
successful people billionaires you know
world champion athletes whatever
um
and there's something interesting that
happens almost I don't know 90 95 of the
time at the end of every episode
from the beginning I always acknowledge
people at the end from what I see in
them after I enter the interview them
for an hour or two I sit there and I'm
like I want to acknowledge you for this
gift that I see in you
number one most people are can't receive
acknowledgment they don't they don't
receive
praise and celebration or acknowledgment
that well you want to know what most
people say at the end when the camera is
done and the lights are off and the mic
shut off
come to me and say
was that good
is that good enough yeah was that was
that okay
and I'm like you're freaking this person
you're desperate you're like
give me some of your talent yeah I'm
like what was it good it was incredible
but it's like we still feel like we need
this
did I say everything the right way
should I set it this way
it's like this need to be still accepted
and like am I enough am I enough okay
before we leave yes you wrote this and I
give it to you right this last question
said
here's the thing about greatness
greatness is not about being complete at
the start it's about being enough even
while you're still growing developing
and changing and as I read that
here's where the tension comes in you
already are enough when you're in this
moment and you're always becoming more
I don't think our culture has a
psychological understanding of the word
enough no because most people are never
satisfied
so how do you balance growing in enough
this is the thing with high Achievers
too it's like
the because they've never been satisfied
that's what's Driven them to get the
results they're at and so they're like
well I don't want to be satisfied
because I'm not going to have this chip
on my shoulder I'm not going to have
this driver this hunger to go for more
and then what then I might lose it all
my Edge my Edge right
and here's the thing
you know the enemy of greatness is
lacking a meaningful mission
in a meaningful mission
is not just about your success for your
benefit it's about your success in the
service of others as well
and when we Define clearly this is the
difference between a greatness mindset
and the power of this mindset when you
define a meaningful Mission which
includes others
you have a renewable energy and you
don't want to stop
and you don't feel like you're burning
out
like I'm on this when it's in service to
somebody else it's in service to others
you might have moments of like okay I'm
exhausted tired yeah like I'm in a
season of like you know foreign abuse
today and traveling on no sleep but I'm
doing it in the service of others not
for me to look good
and now I'm gonna need to go back and
rest and recover and all these things
but I don't feel burnt out I feel
excited every day about what I'm doing
because the mission is Meaningful to me
and it's not about me it's about
including service to other people in the
process so when I measure my worth
based on service to others and my
generosity of my energy my attitude my
effort not on the success of the results
I feel a lot better about me because it
doesn't determine how many books I sell
or how many downloads I have or how many
followers I have determines did I show
up today in service to my mission and if
I did that I am satisfied with my effort
today I am enough today
did I accomplish the mission no so let
me get back up and keep growing and keep
serving but I'm at peace with who I am
and the efforts I have in this moment